we are in beautiful and affordable
Berlin Germany home this is a little
known fact actually the three button
mouse was invented in this building they
were standing out right now no I really
love this community it is amazing I
think that such a big group of people
who are not only inspired by make
the web better they're inspired by each
other right now we are in the wonderful
daddy L system food which is near Austin
half in Berlin it is a expensive
building with a lot of history it seems
so Jas comfy you is a conference that
happens and sort of goal in every year
and it tries to bring together some sort
of bleeding edge work going on in the
JavaScript communities it I guess
thought leaders but also people who were
just packing on some really incredible
sometimes esoteric stuff that is just
crazy but amazing at the same
time
we just had a wonderful talk about
presenting UDP different packet
transfers for better more secure more
fast more reliable and durable transport
mechanism and you pair that with a
hardware talk and we had coppers fly and
you have robots being built and all of
this is happening and growing and
expanding and it's just constantly
changing I for one and just in all at
the spread and the amazing growth and
development of the community sometimes
being a developer it can be very lonely
and you're a lot of your interactions
and learnings it just fine out there not
face to face their via blog posts or via
public places like the Internet where
you may not feel necessarily super
comfortable talking and asking questions
because I think sometimes as developers
we worry that we don't necessarily know
everything Jace conf is a really great
place to just run into people and talk
about stuff stuff that you're not sure
about your stuff that you've played with
but you don't really sure if it you
should use it in a real application or
not yet people who've used things that
you're thinking about using all that
kind of stuff everyone is really open
and people want to talk to each other so
I met a lot of old familiar faces but
already met like way too many people so
they can remember in use anymore and
people are just really willing to share
and I put several people talking about
yeah let's stop this project and I get
this idea and yeah that's the best part
of it if everyone can leave shares
content has a lot of new friends and new
ideas
you